[Musik]
viel spaß die hin und weg wünscht dr
oetker
[Musik]
mit über 30 zu heiraten
barth glück
aber ich habe aus liebe geheiratet
nach oben ist das
ziel was sich dann schlussendlich wird
familie h
punkt
so klar wie bereit aber jetzt gefundene
andere land kennenlernen ist ja nicht so
dass man sich das unbedingt zuerst will
sie schlussendlich ganz einfach
endlich gar nicht
[Musik]
zwei länder
was ich hin
[Musik]
im expert quartier venice golden wie der
chinesische staat wie ich es morgen am 7
der macht sich bereit für sein
arbeitstag sind die frau sharon und pete
johnson sind noch nicht machen
und den grünen
fehlt krank
haben einmal ohne kamera pop-ups
seestern und wenn sie mache stehen
chronische phobie und
wird sich nicht
zu einer schlaufe
entkam ein schlafzimmer mit einer
klammer in der stube das schafft für
mich
das hamburger institut solar auf die
weniger leiden im zweiten stock dass die
kamera natur ist im spielbereich gemacht
und fühle dass die kameras ja solange
baby kamera sie glaubt das nicht
ungewöhnlich aber
matthias in schwiegermutter lebt biene
verständigung ist nicht ganz einfach
dann bist du wieder zu hause
etwa in einer halben stunde
ja
wir haben wir recht keine arrangiere
jetzt über die wenig mit ihr
kommunizieren natürlich aussieht sie
braucht hat zum teil englische wörter
das mega cool und so funktioniert recht
gut dass man suchen kommunizieren und
natürlich genau über smartphone mit dem
übersetzung funktionieren
wenn es golden kürze der besseren
wohngegenden
die meisten nachbarn sind experten der
abteilung matthias
erste partie ob sie in butter im ausland
überhaupt
[Musik]
siebeneinhalb millionen menschen mit
ihrer stadt zu der metropole shanghai
sind nur 150 kilometer
[Musik]
der matthias pendler mit dem auto
die meisten angestellten mit mit dem
shuttlebus zur schweizer
maschinenbaufirma bühne
der 63 jährige matthias ist chef vom
qualitätsmanagement
wie gehts weingut danke
wir haben ein kleines problem okay
der flaschenhalter wurde ausgewechselt
von 35 auf 50 liter
wir können nochmals abklären ob diese
lösung wieder aufnehmen aber die
ziemlich teuer dass eine disco pigs wenn
sie
[Musik]
die haie ist jonathan vorwoche matthias
in die frau sharon krümmt sich um ihre
mutter ist begeistert vom
familiennachwuchs
ich war überrascht und habe mich sehr
über ihre schwangerschaft gefreut
der sharing ihre mutter machte hus haut
china ist familie wichtig dass man mit
mutter und einem dach lebt häufig vor
ich bin schwanger ich brauche deine
hilfe
natürlich habe ich das auch mit matthias
besprochen ob wir unsere mutter zu uns
holen sollen
matthias war einverstanden
für die 60 jährige ist der große und
stetig sie sich und handschuhen der
stadt im nordosten
500 km
sie sagen mir schon was sie denken meine
tochter sagt mir oft was ich machen soll
ich finde das gut
früher konnte ich vieles nicht zum
beispiel den geschirrspüler
ich fand ihn zu kompliziert und glaubte
dass ich von hand viel schneller
abwaschen
es hat ungefähr ein halbes jahr gedauert
bis sie sagte so ein geschirrspüler ist
praktisch ich sollte ihn öfter benutzen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
und gerade vor
gesellschaftlichen druck
das
[Musik]
osteuropa geschäft
aber noch drei vier jahre der schweiz
sind die bäder und mädchen mit ihrer
familie zurück auf ghana die momentan
vierter coup im land bleibt
überhaupt stunden vor der hauptstadt
accra weg lebt ihre mutter und viele
verwandte
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sie sagt wenn du nicht lachst kommen die
menschen nicht zu dir darum ist es
wichtig dass man nachts
zu der gastwirtschaft ghana gehört ihm
raus warum es die ganze familie hilft
mir
noch nicht getrocknet
und dann
geschafft
und wie viel stück herrscht
bei dem frühen tod von vater ist mit 15
die großstadt accra geschaffen
schwierige zeit hat sich von einem haus
bildet aus grafs machen unterstützt sie
ihre familie finanziell
ob mit oder ohne geld ich habe mich nie
verändert
auch das reisen hat mich nicht zu jemand
anderem gemacht ich bin stolz hier zu
sein
manchmal mache ich ferien hier mit den
beiden jungs wir bleiben für drei tage
oder eine woche ich komme immer gerne
hierher zurück
zum suite gibt es national kriegt vor
ghana
machts frucht banane und maniok
unser körper zu die heißt dazu
[Musik]
am nachmittag führte zu dem fußboden und
die beta verfügbar york rote hand
[Musik]
dasselbe
so etwas wie spitze etwas weißes so
apfel
aus demselben stoff
das ist wirklich so
wie
heute gekocht
er studiert das gewünschte
traditionellen roten
[Musik]
wenn du das nicht tust bist du nicht
verheiratet und immer noch single
[Musik]
so
gerne wir muslime bett und natürlich als
210 halter für familienplanung das
machen in halberstadt haupt möglich ist
motte sinnkrise
[Musik]
während matthias anschaffen ist sharon
und ihre mutter geborsten bevor sie die
johnson überholt hat sharon karriere als
geschäftsfrau gemacht
wie der ort ist sie überdies sie dem
alter gilt man als frau tina schon fast
als hoffnungslosen fall aber ihre mutter
janis hexen ihr welle von puppen wie das
vieler anderer machen
meine mutter ist sehr glücklich dass
sich matthias geheiratet habe er kümmert
sich um die familie henkel ist eine sehr
offene person
er akzeptiert kulturelle unterschiede
und andere denkweisen
[Musik]
schweizer firma pure ist weltweit tätig
und hat allein in china 3200 angestellte
[Musik]
hütten im thematisch zusammen mit tina
maschinen
das ist das problem
es wird viel diskutiert aber problem
direkt da spreche ich trainer natürlich
diese masche muss jetzt raus
alle events sichtbare
andere person form eines gesichts und
widersprechen
[Musik]
aber da war es sie dass der kulturelle
unterschied gibt und dass kritisches
thema chemie doch wirklich immer noch
uns drum man kann ja auch
dementsprechend reagieren wenn ich so
situation vorfinden ist das ist dasselbe
und später müssen wir uns markieren
bei gesamten sektor orange kameras die
heimsieben burgsee
es ist - cosima kreis
ist es wohnzimmer in working poor
gewartet so etwas macht
[Musik]
was gibt heute
dass gesundes gemüse
meistens falls mittagspause kurz nach 20
minuten durch selten
der markt bleibt sie bei jordan firma
bülacherin aber jederzeit die zugpferde
von schaffens wie völlig okay wieder
zugespitzt das netzwerk
das höhere macht als
familienauto öbb zu mit spitzkohl
grundsätzlich aber da war halt schon
die ganze familie in betrachtung und
minister diskutieren
magna ist er in ihrem element
die hi ich sie für sie zuständig und
seit der überblick über haushaltsgeld
organisch meistens kocht sie zu hause
sie weiß am besten was wir einkaufen
müssen in diesem markt gehe ich einfach
hinter ihr her
[Musik]
mutter und tochter eines herzliches
verhältnis
zur schweiz und new wave rock wenn ihre
motorik und
es entspricht nicht unserer kultur die
eltern allein zu lassen
[Musik]
wir sollten uns um die eltern kümmern
wenn sie alt werden
das ist der kreis des lebens
wenn wir jung sind kümmern sie sich um
uns wenn sie alt werden schauen wir zu
ihnen
wohin ich auch gehe du kommst mit biss
aber klar doch
ich lass dich doch nicht allein
[Musik]
als wir uns entschieden haben zusammen
zu leben ließen wir niemanden zwischen
uns kommen und hörten nicht auf
diejenigen die nicht auf unserer seite
waren nur ein paar wenige
mein vater hat sie geliebt und sagt er
immer endlich hast du die richtige
gefunden sie macht mich glücklich das
tut sie immer noch elf jahren
[Musik]
silvio und brigit mit dem jamie dem
reservat von native americans ihren
mardschah kürze starten er ist sehr
spirituell und vor ihm hat brigitta aus
morgenritual übernahm
es ist ihre zum dvb t das ist jay
schnell vor der krebsoperation erholt
ja
das ist so ich spiele
eine kleine [ __ ]
und das ist für den job
das geht positive energie also von
zusammenhang von schlaf dass das buch
defizit ist bisher die energie
wiederaufbau hat ja schon
die leute
wissen der guten arzt
riet sie jetzt schon lange schweizer zu
ihren töchtern
28 also hieß es schon vor seiner
krankheit planen es gibt viel zu
organisieren zum beispiel
krankenkassen finde
das hd2 man braucht und mit dem oscar
prämierten bus und
behauptet die
firma ich bereit jetzt wird große umzug
wirklichkeit es sind jahre her seit ich
zuletzt in der schweiz war die familie
wieder zu sehen ja ich freue mich
wirklich
alles hier muss mit
und die schallplatten und
hier auf dem tisch aber
die lampes und der schädel
muss sich noch singen operation nur
schonen
er bleibt klasse droht zum ganze wirbel
und dome
aus sicht der native americans ist alles
so gekommen wie es muss wir haben sogar
schon eine wohnung da drüben ihre
tochter hat sie uns eingerichtet das
visa die flugtickets der hund alles ist
so dass wir jetzt gehen können
[Musik]
wir werden ihn in der schweiz wieder
sehen
es ist real wirklich real
ich muss mich setzen ich kann nicht
länger stehen
der abschied und nöcher
bald sind die beide für 2 min jetzt
brennt umso mehr genießt die gemeinsamen
momente
für dich wein und für mich gibt limonade
wir heben die täler und bedanken uns
beim schöpfer der mutter dem vater
unseren ahnen dem universum für essen
und freunde
wie schön wir sollten das öfter machen
die beide wüste was young und und sie
sind dankbar für ihren sport die liebe
es gibt nichts vergleichbares sie kommt
immer an erster stelle ich kann nur
sagen das ist liebe und ich würde alles
für sie tun und ich weiß sie würde alles
für mich
[Musik]
beide hoffen dass er bald anreise aber
alles hängt von rex unterhaltung
ja
august 2011 da haben wir also das gut
aber eben nicht so dass
ich gestern absicht
das kulturzentrum ist ein gemeinsamer
traum der b4 und im beet oxy er haben
sie in die liga schafft für musik aus
leibe um englisch druckt autoren das rät
islam als musiklehrer schlafe
gern major-sieger 5 im umgang mit gästen
vom rechten rand
[Musik]
auch für die vielfach stellten ich sie
zuständig und für die zwei hotelzimmer
the behavior vorjahr gar mit wähler auf
ghana zugleich aber der beta ist
überzeugt dass ein wechsel richtig
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
laut peta hat wüste wasser sich lilo
noch sie musikstudiums jahr in ghana
klebt wählen die afrikanischen trommlern
interessierte and
chips und ghana zwei komplett
unterschiedliche länder das buch mit
familie mit zwei kindern hits von
pflanzen
zum kulturzentrum bauer hätte bäder sind
pensionskassen auflöst
iris reihe höchstens formierte das hilft
zum baugrund größte decker
[Musik]
der führte peter jetzt betreuen
vormachen der bekannte musiker atom
codes in bar ich bin muss ich sido xii
jetzt nimmt er mit ihm zweimal gerufen
wo die ruskin stoffen geht um viel
ja
muss aber der gemacht genauere auskünfte
darüber machen und
[Musik]
das ist so fliegen im businessplan
musikschau im lepper für die beiden
söhnen und levin
[Musik]
so
forscht uhr
europa
[Musik]
der beta und mafia unterstützen kind aus
armen familien dass die renditen musik
machen
pinky zum beispiel hat danken projekt
des entertainment schon verschiedene
brise coole musik keine chance für das
anders vielleicht spacelab
[Musik]
das war das soundcheck für die hipster
kinder von dennis entertainment die in
einer stunde auftreten werden
also bleibt hier um neben noch einen
drink
[Musik]
ja super
arbeit gemacht
ich habe richtig gut
die
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ganz andere pläne hätten evans in brühe
dort leben er wörter für das studium
[Musik]
zörbig brettert band wo die typische
musikus im norden vor ghana spielen
melanie nachts beten
[Musik]
derby ist grenzenlos sein aber führt
andrea und ihren freund sind
landesgrenze in überwindbare hürde
zweimal sie uns erst wenn es kühler sind
und für das buch sein werk vor dokument
aber hüten sich endlich bist du
[Musik]
ja aber es ist schon speziell
spezielle
marketingfachfrau andrea hat sich eine
szene und die columbia kreist date
erzielt pedro keine klubs längst zieht
sechs nur gut die kollegen der petro und
ursprünglich aus venezuela kolumbien ist
übersetzer und macht uhr ez partita die
sagenumwobenen die ruine stand
seit einem jahr sind er und andreas
bauer ob ihre liebesgeschichte des happy
end ich hoffe die beiden steckt immer
endlose probiert
es hat man kassa sie sind jetzt mit der
bush-politik dokument garten mit oder
und die doku man kann man kann dieses
antragsteller nicht machen kann die
therapie so können sie
ja
hoffentlich
gut und dir
okay aber aufgeregt sind sie da
ja
ich war heute morgen auf der post
sie sind hier
wirklich ist alles korrekt
auf vielen seiten wird bestätigt ja
alles echt ja er ist single mit vielen
apostille
klar hat das so lange gedauert aber
haben sie von allen zwei geschenkt
ja eine mit und eine ohne apostel
warum das kapiert nicht dasselbe
dokument einmal mit einmal ohne apostel
weil es sonst teurer wäre und mehr zeit
bräuchten
aber dann sind wir bereit
außer der übersetzung
wie lange dauert das
sie meinten acht tage wir sind also
einen schritt weiter wir
haben immer noch einen langen weg vor
uns
ja eine ewigkeit
aber wir sind einen schritt weiter das
ist am wichtigsten
ja
einen guten tag wünsche ich dir und
friedrich mit allem
ich hoffe alles klappt
gute nacht träum schön
[Musik]
ja und muss man muss damit leben lernen
mit mit dem stern du einfach da schon
härter sind auch in der schweiz
das ist so und
korruption
in staat und
geschäfte machen
[Musik]
jetzt mache ich mehr grip der medizin
gehören im fuß
aus dem schlaf weil die machen sich
jetzt so ihre bahnen
fuhren
die bahnen die
ladentische yahoo
das ist aber nimmt
trotzdem
[Musik]
herrscht weiter behandeln malaria ich
hab immer
mediziner
aber noch zehn minuten später als sie
zweiter in diesem ton
und deine
[Musik]
aber wiederum löste damit naturmedizin
probiere
man steht schon kurz darauf wieder zu
einen doch es ist im budget zum
akw um infos
sind wir sehr bitter und besserer sex
damit stehe abstellen muss
ist das denkbar
satz nicht
schon in barcelona und in frage bitte
sehr gute idee ist damit
also den schweizer
medizinbereich dem vater
ist es einfach
nicht gemacht
und
ist ohne komplikationen
die gute nachricht sein haus behandle
machen
[Musik]
endlich ist er da der große tag
verbringt und ihre töchter
die erwartete wir immer topfit aus der
usa zu
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
saisontor
[Musik]
die nächste volk vor hin und weg wieder
matthias der schweiz und china bringt
sie ist meisterin im zopf flechten
time bäckerei wird immer professioneller
und beansprucht im moment es sowieso
schon knapp befreit sind
regis lang mit dollars und leipzig ii
fällt deren überaus
[Musik]
wie geht's dir viel viel besser
auch gut und die leute hier sind alle
sehr nett es wird uns sehr gefallen
[Gelächter]
angie und
traumfrau gefunden der weg zu einem
dreifachsieg der turm geht alles zu
integrieren
ist das die zunge
er ist zwar hat rational
[Musik]
die keller
red
[Musik]
hinunter ich präsentiert wurde von dr
oetker